[Music]
but I was starting my vlog Oh No go
ahead hey guys happy national cookie day
today we are celebrating by while not
eating actually we are eating cookies
already had cookies today well we're
celebrating because guess what guess who
has officially been announced and
crowned the winner of the cookie jam
holiday baked off baby me me me me me me
thank you guys so much for voting I was
so excited and you done a both decided
to freeze our cookies your brown icing
looked not good bye look good
absolutely I know how the internet works
and look at this I'm fantastic I'm
saving these for the rest of my life
anyway thank you guys again for voting
for me I appreciate it that was 10,000
of you guys voted and I'm so excited now
I'm going to be wearing my cookie crown
for the rest of the day today
if you guys want to get the recipe I'll
put a link in the description where you
guys can download cookie jam and you get
the full recipe there in the game but
now I'm gonna take you guys on behind
the scenes of our day today we are
filming the last bit of our holiday
videos and oh boy I've filmed a lot
hello Nick yo how's it going you're
gonna have to take us through the setup
because I've taken them through my setup
previously but my setup I use all Sony
and Nick uses Panasonic the G H fives I
mentioned this to you guys briefly
before but we'll take a look and I'll
show you guys what we're shooting with
how is this setup different than my
previous sony a7s to set up we don't
have to cut that's Panasonic will run
forever until the card runs out we've
got 2 G H 5s one's got a meta bones
adapter with the Sigma 18 to 35 art over
here we've got the Lumix lens I can't
remember what it is the one that came
out with the gh 5 we're shooting in log
superraw super-wrong
beautiful I love this like so much it
looks so great yeah I think it looks
good here we are cool
okay this is behind the scenes of our
first video that we're shooting today I
wonder when I'll post this video I'm not
sure here you go yes it's in the bowl no
yet okay we have to melt this so get
that melted up so can I put in the bowl
no melt it looks good so I don't why can
I put it in this bowl I don't want it in
that bowl yes because it because I have
to put in the dry and I'm not sure
actually I think so okay plug it fortune
cookie maker and preheat for five
minutes oh we've been filming for a
while but like we really haven't
accomplished much but now we're taking a
break to eat food because we ate so many
fortune cookies and now we're watching
the debut of your character in viscid
what is it several watches it's the
finale of East Lewis high of the movie
on Hulu and I play the character Rupert
who is described in the action as frumpy
and rich are you from be are you rich
you don't work this is gonna be exciting
Jen asleep I wonder how many of them
watch this show or have watched it
there's five season is this you yet are
you where you at are you when you see
it's two cops room later
kinda sexy it's perfect
and so is this hotel my husband and I
have done a lot of events here Oh
[Music]
pleasure to meet you I went to need to
have the wedding number dreams and
dreams are our specialty isn't that
right ceci I will call you grab your
purse you loving it you I hate watching
myself that's grace there has been an
ongoing running prank of the house
thanks to Jenna Ned and Jeff Burke they
have been hiding clowns in my house
everywhere so now the thing to do was to
pass it on to somebody else
this is terrifying look at this thing
it's disgusting
look where did you get this that's Jenna
yes waiting for my laptop there's this
it's super terrifying I don't think I
saw but one day ROH posted on her
channel that she found one and then she
hid it in Kandi's makeup kit but I'm not
sure if kandi ever found or not oh
speaking of which kandi
it is time to open today's December 4
advent calendar Maddie what are you
doing in here what are you doing you
want to go outside
what do you want to do honey Maddy seems
sad today are you okay honey all right
well I'm gonna open up my advent
calendar for today December 4th what's
it gonna be I basically just gave myself
a paper cut over a severe burn oh my god
please me a minifig oh it's not the
minifigure ones are my favorite I mean
these are cool but I'm really just
gunning for that stormtrooper and the
bb-8 which is probably later in the
month go check on Maddie what are you
doing out here sweetheart
this is gonna be a great shot home this
is a video for Jenna's channel thank you
I don't want to show them what it is
that I want to spoil it gonna be you
know lit actual we got a new light up
here because since I got another new
light that's been casting a shadow in my
face so we had to mount this little
thing
look at this rig you've got rigged up by
weight so it's a little key light I
can't wait till this this slo-mo shot
happens what are you trying to boost up
wesen vegetable oil get that buttery
shot guys okay yeah this is indie
filmmaking at its finest right here
we're making bones a little bit of time
happy new year just kidding it's we're
still a national cookie day videos but
there
eight cameras rollin we're about beta I
can read uh we need a light off oh my
god I have no no it's not rolling yet
because there's no ID on there you do to
my house Jenna oh my gosh poor Matty
hi honey lights out radio boiler alert
spoiler alert oh my gosh this place is a
mess hi Matty what did you do what is
all this okay blog 11:28 and this is
what we're doing
Matty what's happening buddy we've
ruined your we ruined your living rooms
we're filming pretty much the last
Christmas video and I'm so excited there
wait there is sort of well it's like I
guess he's like Christmas themed but we
there's that's it doesn't matter
oh wow
I think that's pretty much it now it's
time to edit oh my goodness happy
vlogmas guys i just wanna say hello and
thanks for watching and I will see you
guys tomorrow for whatever video it
happens to be next I'm not sure we've
got a lot of them coming out so I look
forward to posting them but now we have
to finish this last one so that we can
officially be done okay
that's a roll bye guys
[Music]